and our last speaker for the session
is jenny chronic associate product
manager at nanostring technologies
who will propose solutions of spatial
profiling in using geomics fully
validated antibodies
i'm jenny cronin i'm an associate
product manager at nanostring
i work with the geomix dsp system
specifically on our protein
assays and i'm here to talk about our
protein offerings and our fully
validated antibodies to meet your
spatial profiling needs
as you've likely already heard during
the conference the geomix
digital spatial profiler uses our
patented dna barcoding technology
to attach synthetic dna oligonucleotide
barcodes
to antibodies or to rna probes and this
enables you to spatially profile your
tissue
in any region of interest so we can walk
through our simple workflow here
on the left hand side you see the first
step which for a protein assay is to
stain your slide with fluorescent
antibodies
and with our antibodies that are
conjugated to our dsp barcodes
this can be done on an auto standard or
you can do it manually
next the system will scan your slide and
you'll select regions of interest you
can select regions of interest from
anywhere on your slide and we call these
rois
and if you want to you can take a single
any roi and you can segment it meaning
you could separate it into
for example the tumor and the tumor
micro environment
next in step three you'll see the system
goes through and picks from each of
those regions of interest one at a time
or if you've segmented it'll pick from
each segment one at a time
as the barcodes are released using uv
light
a micro capillary system will sip up the
tags and then in step four
dispense them into a 96 well plate
you can then take those bar codes in our
final step on the right
and read them out with either our
encounter platform or on an illumina
sequencer
for our encounter readout we have over
200 validated antibodies
this large selection of validated
protein content is bucketed into our
amino oncology bucket with over 140
targets for human and mouse
and a neuroscience bucket with over 75
targets
for our human i o content we are about
to release three new panels you'll see
them at the
on the bottom left in the i o space
those are the map case signaling panel
the pi 3k akt signaling panel
and the cell death panel our content is
designed in a core and module format and
you'll see this illustrated on the right
you have to choose a core module with
about 20 plex
with additional controls and that can be
a human i o core
a mouse io core or a human neural core
you then have the choice to add up to
six different ten plex
modules onto that core lastly if you'd
like
you can add an additional 10 custom
antibodies
bringing you to 96 plex for your
experiment
now i'd like to look in a little more
detail at the i o content
for our human immuno oncology portfolio
again we have that core
it's here in the green table and the
core is
one of our broad broad panels it'll
allow
it includes key immuno oncology targets
and markers of immune cells
including t cells b cells and
macrophages
on the right hand side of the slide
you'll see four of our seven total
modules we'll go through the next three
in a moment of these four
modules again they're all approximately
10 plex
the cell typing module is the most broad
the cell typing module can allow you to
profile a range of specialized cell
types including macrophages
and regulatory t cells
next the immune activation status module
can help you more deeply profile immune
exhaustion
the io drug target module includes
additional checkpoint and immune
modulatory targets that are currently
under development for io therapies
some of those targets such as pdl-1 are
in the core but this module includes
additional targets that might be of
interest to you
and lastly on this slide our pan tumor
module can allow you to more deeply
profile the tumor
here on the right hand side you'll see
our three new human io modules that'll
be released shortly they're going
through our validation process now which
i'll talk about short in a moment
the map case signaling module and the
pi3k akt
signaling module will both be of
interest to those who are studying
targeted therapies against
one of these pathways and they both
include phosphorylated protein products
that
measure pathway activation
lastly our cell death module will allow
you to profile the tumor
um and and mediators of immunogenic and
programmed cell death
for our mouse models out there our mouse
immuno oncology portfolio includes the
core
and four total modules
those are the immune cell typing module
the immune activation status
io drug target and pan tumor later this
year we'll also be expanding this
content
to match what uh the human io content
that we've just gone over to include
those two new signaling
pathway panels and the cell death panel
as i mentioned earlier all of the
antibodies that we offer commercially
go through a thorough validation process
i'd like to show you some data from that
now
our validation process is broken down
into five steps shown here
on the left you see the first step which
is an ordering screen here we
validate our off-the-shelf antibodies in
control tissue
next they go through a post conjugation
screen to test the specificity of the
conjugated antibody
the third step we go through a
sensitivity and specificity screen
then an interaction screen to make sure
all the antibodies will work
in combination with one another and
finally we go through
a tma screen to make sure to
ensure that the antibodies perform as
we'd expect in real tissue
now looking at each of these steps with
some data from antibodies from our three
new
human i o panels here we show the pre
and post conjugation screen
on the top row of all of these um ihc
images
you'll see our unconjugated antibodies
and the bottom row is the conjugated
antibodies
these four different antibodies shown
here are included in our map k
our cell death or our pi3k akt signaling
panels
our nanostring pathologist reviews all
of this data to ensure that they we have
the same pattern of binding both pre
and post conjugation
all the antibodies that pass that step
go to a specificity screen next
during the specificity screen we first
use our encounter system
to measure the rna expression levels in
a number of different cell lines
and they're shown here um in a small
gray text on the x-axis
we then compare these measured those
levels to our measured protein
expression levels
and make sure that our proteomic profile
makes sense in light of this transcript
transcriptomic profile that we've just
measured
and as you can see here especially
looking
um between the rna on the top graph and
the protein on the bottom graph
those those levels vary with one another
as we'd expect
here we show some more specificity data
again across a set of cell lines and
what i'll point out here is that in the
top graph
the second and third bars there are for
a431
and caliculin a cell lines
and you can see that the phospho in the
yellow and the top line the phospho
map k irc12 has a higher expression
level
in the calculon a stim cell line than it
does in the a431 cell line now this is
what we'd expect
since the calculation a inhibits
phosphatases
those antibodies that pass our
sensitivity and specificity screen move
on to an interaction screen
as i mentioned this is to make ensure
that all the antibodies can work
uh alongside one another because again
we have this
panel um panel setup where you use a
core and you add on additional modules
so here we look at our human i o core on
the x-axis
and on the y-axis you see the log
log2 signal to noise for our human i o
core plus
a number of different modules so each of
those the lines represented here
is for a different module or a different
set of modules added to the core
we do a number of different combinations
again to ensure that the performance of
the antibodies
um alone matches the performance of the
antibodies in the cocktail of different
uh modules you can see the r values in
the table to the right
the correlation is high our values that
are always greater than 0.9
finally all of those antibodies that
have passed this test
up to this point go through a tma screen
in the tma screen we use tissue
microarray arrays to look at the
differential expression
across different tissues and including
cancer
and non-cancer tissues and ensure that
our antibodies
in these core and module setups are
going to work in real world samples
so as we've discussed our geomix dsp
portfolio
of pre-validated content in both i o and
neuroscience
includes over 200 different antibodies
all of these antibodies go through a
robust validation pipeline
so you can use the reagents off the
shelf without having to spend months or
even years to validate that content
if there's an antibody of interest to
your research that you've used in the
past and you want to add in here you can
also do that
i mentioned you can add up to 10
different custom antibodies
you can do 10 from nanostring or five
total from abcam
appcam has greater than 6000 antibodies
for custom conjugation to pick from
so you can make our match our protein
core
and our modules with that additional
custom content to meet whatever your
spatial profiling needs are our custom
content goes through
um a different set of validation it
doesn't get fully validated as i just
laid out
but if ordered through ad cam it does go
through a pre and post conjugation
screen so that you can be
assured that it will work in ihc so i'd
like to leave you with that now
knowing that we have over 200 different
antibodies that are fully validated
and we're happy to talk with you more
about the geomix digital spatial
profiler
thank you
what if the antibodies i want aren't in
these files
that's a great question if the
antibodies aren't in our core
or our module panels right now then you
can use custom content so you can use
up to five different antibodies from
abcam they've got over 6000 antibodies
to choose from that will work with
geomixed dsp
or you could add up to 10 custom
antibodies through our nanostring
protein barcoding service
[Music]
how are custom antibodies validated
so custom antibodies do not go through
the same validation process
as the rest of our commercially
available antibodies
if you order a custom antibody from
abcam
then it'll go through a pre and a post
ihc screen
if you order a custom antibody from us
we are
unable to offer the pre and post ihc
screen instead we ask that you only send
us
antibodies that that have been validated
by the by the supplier in ihc
and then we will test just like app cam
will to ensure that the
olgo tag or that barcode tag has been
properly conjugated to the antibody
but again unlike abcam we're not able to
offer a post ihc test
suny post conjugation ihc test
do you have any mouse neuroscience core
or modules available
we currently don't have mouse
neuroscience
panels available for geomics however our
available human content has a decent
amount of cross reactivity and we can
provide you some information on that
additionally we will be releasing mouse
neuroscience content
at the end of this year
what new balance what new panels
are you planning so for
new panel development we're looking in
the mouse space so we'll be adding
first mouse io content that content will
allow um
the mouse io content to match what we
have available in human i o content so
that'll be adding the pi 3k akt
signaling uh panel a map case signaling
panel and a cell death panel
those antibodies won't be exactly the
same as they are in our human
panels but we do our best to to have
consistency across those panels
and then we will also be adding our
mouse neuroscience panels
will protein content be available for
ngs readout
yes protein content is in our plan to
make for ngs readout
currently it's only available for end
counter readout which is why you're
limited to the 96 plex currently
but we do have plans to release protein
for ngs
and that will allow that plex to
increase as well
are there any concerns that the index in
oligo interferes with the antibody
binding
that's another great question the main
one of the primary reasons we do our pre
and post
conjugation ihc is to ensure there
hasn't
that in this indexing oligo or that that
barcode that we use
has not inferior interfered with how the
antibody binds so we look to ensure that
we have similar patterns
um in those ihc stains both pre
and post conjugation